for sure but they just think that they
would be
yeah for sure
so what's uh
what is this just put this you can if
you want to sounds better
all right you're more aware of when
you're what your volume is you can
control the volume okay cool let's do it
wait is this filmed yeah all right it's
going right now there's one right there
that one's the main one that
oh
wait a minute
is that going in are we recording yet
yeah
that's streaming
oh it's streaming right now
right now yeah
so who
so like probably like 200 people at
first and then like maybe like 500. I
don't know well yeah we gotta did
anybody see that thing fall down we can
edit that out right well we'll just have
to kill whoever saw that yeah they
didn't record it yeah we'll hunt you
down screen recording this
all right if you said anything
embarrassing on a podcast
uh
uh no no it's I guess it's kind of hard
these days you know like because
everybody's
so aware of it you know yeah like I
haven't done a pod I've said some wild
[__] but not embarrassed stuff yeah but
that's part of the art of podcasting
yeah I was just trying to like
Elevate and shock a lot of people like
it's not some people are afraid to say
anything yeah you don't want to get
canceled yeah yeah how many good
podcasts have been ruined by fear of
cancellations
and is it worth it
I think so well I mean but also people
have been canceled into careers I mean
my man Shane Shane Gillis you know they
were just [__] around and you know uh
you had a shame I know Shane of course
he's one of the best comedians in the
world right now yeah and ever in history
yeah actually like you know like do you
think right now it's like the LeBron era
yeah and like there might have been
Michael Jordan's in the past but on a
one-on-one yeah basis we just know so
much more about comedy now we're just so
comedic now yeah yeah yeah yeah he's a
beast yeah definitely but that his uh
you know that was a podcast that they
were just he was [__] yeah the
Chinatown bit Yeah and then that was
literally just them [__] around you
know yeah he wasn't like declaring you
know what I mean hey it wasn't a speech
you know I mean it was a [__] copy
like that yeah if you want to go to
where you should get your morals from go
to a church like why are you going to a
comedy show feeling this is morally
reprehensible so crazy people bring in
their morals to [__] shows and
podcasts like what do you you know there
are stuff for that too like you said
there's churches there's like political
rallies exactly yeah but not a [__]
uh comedic podcast but now like I've
invited people in the past when I had
one and they'd be like oh I'd love to
come but I don't wanna well I think
comedy plays on morals and like breaking
morals and if morale is kind of sketchy
then you can't be like oh I want to you
know Murder a Serbian man because
they're like oh you might actually do
that that's like the kind of climate
that we're in yeah exactly like that's
the thing is the people who get mad are
the ones where the Nuance is lost right
like you you don't understand
that it's okay to joke about murdering
somebody like you you know I'm like when
you talk about slaves you're not
Mastered on you're not murdering so much
that you have to like have this
Elementary like recognition of it we
can't even joke about it that's it yeah
yeah they're like you can't talk about
it at all or else I'm gonna murder
somebody yeah it's like you can't joke
about it we talk about like race too
that's the only thing you should do is
joke about murdering people yeah yeah
you shouldn't practice it or and race
and murdering specifically murdering
other races yeah if you don't have a
good sense of humor about it then
but don't you find that that's that's
what like a lot of people it's mostly
white women that I found that get
married they get mad at anything like
anybody that's ever come up to me after
a show it's it's been a white woman and
sometimes the comments
it'll mostly be white women sometimes
it'll be like a white dude
trying to be a white woman or trying to
[__] a white woman yeah like a lot of
stamps you know like a lot of guys that
are like I'm so well I think it's good
that they're doing that because it it's
not good to just have a lot of masculine
energy just being like [__] midgets
you know it's like hey we should
actually care about some things we we
need the cuck Boy energy yeah it has to
balance out it can't be all alpha males
yeah we need some some Michael Sarahs
yeah you can't all be uh uh uh Joe
Rogan's yeah I mean we need some uh some
Jonah Hills
did you see what happened to Jonah Hill
yes what did you think of that was he
because I thought I've been there and
it's like cringy to watch someone go
through it but it's like you can't
control women they're gonna do whatever
you're just lucky to have the time that
you have with them yeah yeah you mean so
it's so it's his fault for even texting
because if you have a com I feel like if
you have a sensitive or have to have a
sensitive conversation with a woman it's
better to talk in person yeah right or
even call because sometimes
he's on the road a lot he's an active
world famous so he's probably not seeing
her he's trying to do this long distance
or uh long-term thing
it's just a mess and he's just like a
child he never grew up he got rewarded
early yeah yeah yeah and he well he
asked I mean several things were wrong
one the [__] posted the private text
for no reason it was unprompted a year
later a year later a year later this guy
just had a a kid so it's like even if
you're mad at this guy uh even if you
have a good reason to be mad at him
why'd you wait why'd you sit on it for a
year and then wait till he had a kid
yeah Miss what are you doing what's the
purpose of that is he has to get
attention for you you're not solving
anything now people are mad also he
didn't him laying out his standards or
whatever he required it might have been
a double standard but that's still you
you can just say no you can be like go
[__] yourself yeah you have to be
offended at him saying hey hit you he
did it verbally insult you it was really
well like thought well worded it's like
he said perfectly describing insecurity
and talk to him and simp Behavior it
makes sense to him yeah yeah it was like
and and his mind is like this is uh
that's all you get for trying to [__] a
[__] that is what you get that's what
you mean if you want to [__] Jason Momoa
man then go function yeah like if you
sign up for Jonah Hill
that's what you get you get you get
passive aggressive texts
with Jason you you get you know [__]
for hours yeah he's like you can't [__]
anyone now yeah it's like Jason you're
having a good time I gotta prepare my
[__] for his giant [__] exactly yeah
but with Jonah it's just got you know
you're getting
where you at Texas
yeah Naggy kind of like you gotta stop
it's like a lesbian relation someone who
wants something more than dumb men they
want like a
they want an equal tennis partner yeah
intellectually spar with someone every
day yeah yeah yeah
well but then some people just want
somebody not to spar word but like to
control yeah you know like some some the
simplest dumbest people want to control
people yeah people that can actually
control people don't want to do it
because it's weird yeah yeah but yeah
people that can't like people have no
personality and they're like come here
we'll sit here and watch this now yeah
like the dudes that just work out all
the time that's their personality Jim
Bros yeah
yeah like you can go to the gym and
that's great but if that's your whole
identity
you know I mean like that's not enough
actually absolutely yeah but I don't
know some women also a lot of women are
dumb too so like some of these hoes yeah
some girl is like all I need is the
shopping bag
and the best some coffee
that she has a good impersonation I
think I [__] her before that girl that
specific one all I need is a
shopping
[Laughter]
back and put my tampons in yeah
some high heels some let's give me some
glitter and some high heels and I'm good
to go give me a a pot in the pan
watching my girlfriend it's like it must
be so nice to be a girl to go out to
bars and just get anything
than just to like play with people yeah
yeah like you can you ever been to a gay
bar that's how it is that's how I went
to a gay bar one time you're like
actively a participant in a bar like you
go to a straight bar you're like oh get
away we're trying to get to the real
people yeah well I
I I at a gay bar I do feel like a bad
[__] like I get free drinks like you
know like it is
people are trying to [__] people like
you there people want you there they
want me to keep you around and you know
what it's a little forceful sometimes
because I'll say no and then the gay
guys are like okay yeah
I can still I mean they still try to
[__] me but I'm like I said no no means
no so sometimes no does mean no
I realize that but then
you know I mean it's like yeah I mean
some of them here's the problem
is
uh I wasn't I didn't feel threatened at
any point right at any point none of
them are like dudes you could at least
get five seconds to be like help
yeah yeah yeah unless they all like just
assaulted me at once like as a mob then
it's a wrap but I think yeah as as a guy
it's less dangerous like yeah as a woman
you must feel so hopeless because you're
designed to not be able to do this yeah
yeah yeah and you're attracted to people
that can do that yeah man so you're
always around people that can murder you
that's true but the free drinks though I
mean it's great
the Social Power you get to be like
excuse me bartender this guy has stepped
out of line and then they'll they'll get
kicked out
yeah yeah yeah so they they're in like a
safe environment safe fish
have you heard about all the druggings
happening in Austin in Austin
specifically yeah because I know it's
just happening I know in the world in
the world yeah people are desperate yeah
do you think it's because the pandemic
I know the pandemic made people hornier
yeah it's like facts I know there's more
homeless people right and so it's like
homeless people are [__]
well everyone on the middle class just
got bummed down and now they don't have
that tiny new Jeep so they just gotta go
drugging people yeah it did get I think
I think the pandemic made people uh uh
poorer and hornier for sure and so what
are you gonna do you know I mean you
don't got money for drinks you know it's
like do I buy
four drinks or one roofie these are just
the economy
these are the the decisions we have to
make in Biden economy
your people being forced
yeah just to have sex just have sex they
don't want to do this yeah but it's
we're in a deficit you see so that's why
the pan is near to come off no is it a
thing in Austin though is it like a yeah
more so here yeah but they arrested some
ladies and they found them in Atlanta
so it's like they were saying ladies
yeah they were doing it they would I
thought man would do this wait a minute
hold on wait a back up I'm sure it's
mostly men but like some ladies you know
women love poison that's their thing of
choice it is that's a woman's drug yeah
so they but hold on explain the story so
they drug people took their wallets and
credit cards and then they wound up oh
they drugged them yeah to Rob them oh
they caught oh they got cardi B right
cardi B did that right is that the thing
at our strip club when she was stripping
I think somebody did it maybe it was
Nicki Minaj they all blur together I
think cardi B somebody like fat ass yeah
uh Mary J Blige No it was cardi B I
think she joked about drugging men and
robbing them and she talked about it
like it was okay
well rappers joke about like raping I
guess XXX yeah all right yeah if it's
doing that beat it's okay if you admit
to it I don't think anyone rapes women
like that's in the top like 100 rappers
no but like cardi that's still that's
how women that this is what gets me
about women they think that they're
incapable of evil they say that if the
world was run by women there'd be no
I've heard that several times but you
got cardi B openly
happy about it so obviously about it
yeah so obviously
entitled to that and card you know what
I mean uh more power to her yes Queen
you know what I mean like hashtag uh get
that money but what I'm saying is
obviously women are capable of some foul
[__] I mean you can't just go around
drugging people and robbing them that's
crazy yeah
that's so rude but so that's just Rob
them just Robin if you drug me that's
like an extra level yeah yeah yeah
because you're [__] with the insides
if you take things from outside of me
that's fine
I think that's well don't that's me
don't drug or Rob me that's my stuff
that's my stance on on that yeah if I
can help I'm just a liberal I just want
to get robbed so that I can pay back for
all the crimes that I've committed yeah
yeah well but you're you're Asian you're
not even like white that's like you
didn't what did you what crimes did you
you know I mean I mean I just skated by
and came in at the last minute and
enjoyed the the fruits of the hard work
done by people before me I guess that's
true that's uh have a wheel isn't that
Society American that's definitely
American that's America you're more
that's cheers of that man lazy
yeah just uh no nothing's more American
than unearned wealth come on man that's
it
yeah the Native Americans they all died
because Americans were disgusting yeah
and they got coughed on and they had
like the most foul diseases and they got
90 of their population wiped out yeah
so I don't want to hear about it about
covid
it's a drop in the bucket
yeah they didn't have vaccines back then
they did all right they just had to have
heard immunity they did yeah that's they
didn't have fouchy yeah I mean and they
did just fine
yeah
that's a good point so but wait a minute
uh oh yeah you have a girlfriend yes how
long you guys been together six months
nice I think wait did you just post her
yeah Instagram I just saw that yeah yeah
that's hilarious this there I posted it
I said here
because it's been a thing it's like why
aren't you posting me oh she was asking
you to post her yeah wow okay well I
kind of want her to post me on her
Instagram I didn't post you no no maybe
on the stories or something no but not
on the ground like profile grid so why
was she it was like a game of chicken
like who's that who's gonna post who
first yeah hey you caved I posted her
yeah I've wanted a poster I just you
know yeah trying to find a good time
okay there's the guy you know is she
gonna post you
it's better yeah listen if she doesn't
post you then that was a fun
relationship
that'd be crazy to not post yeah yeah
well then it's like I don't I don't
really mind you know like if she's not
we're not yeah that's crazy because like
because girls that's all they do yeah
but you know maybe I'm like Bobby Lee
and she's like khalila
oh you found your kalila yeah like she's
settling and yeah yeah one of the one of
the perks is that she doesn't have to
post me
but hey if I trapped her I trapped her
isn't that like awesome that I can track
I guess people
I guess so yeah that's that's that's
pretty cool but uh
no I think she's gonna post now I think
I'm that ugly and Men know Hey listen
handsome I I don't know no that's that's
fair enough but also you know uh we all
uh we dream of having our own kalila you
know what I mean yeah there's people
that would kill I think it makes the
most sense to me I've just grown up to
be is she who what does she do who is
she she's just a person she's just
normal human
strategy planning supply chain
okay management all right okay it got
more clearer but the first two words
were like strategy planning what I was
trying to think of it off that it's all
the same to me yeah
she's just planning is just definitely
nothing a lot of planning going on well
hey white people be planning man she's
white right yeah okay yeah yeah she's
good white people let me plan it man
they got plans yeah she's she's been
known for fun she's like yeah she's like
a good time which is that's great yeah
that I like she's a normal person that's
good yes
yeah he hasn't been scarred by
capitalism not yet well but this is a
pretty isn't this a this is like
a Republican state right like it's
turning purple ish that's pretty cool
yeah I mean you know all the major
cities Dallas Houston and Austin San
Antonio are pretty Democratic really
yeah it's just maybe not as much as
California City maybe there's like a
higher percentage well yeah everybody's
leaving the Liberals they're done
[__] up California so now they're
they're migrating elsewhere like a virus
like well you've corrupted this let's
[__] spread it's funny because
they're they're escaping but they're
also carrying the thing I mean what what
if like Californians are like wow we
made such an awesome thing that
everyone's moving here let's move
somewhere else and create awesome things
over there too
well that's actually literally what Joe
Rogan did so it's so funny yeah Joe came
from Cali to here to create more awesome
more awesomeness that's right I mean the
mothership is a lot like The Comedy
Store yeah in a lot of ways man if it
works don't if it ain't broke don't fix
it yeah it's worse I mean we've been to
so many comedy clubs and yeah like
either it's like a headliner club with
these massive showrooms
and like you know
one room and it's like hard to build a
scene there but if you have multiple
rooms you can double the amount of
energy and kinetics meetings and
friction yeah absolutely showcase style
yeah comedians booked yeah it's [__]
it's it's insane but yeah Texas is uh a
lot of people are coming here
and I heard a lot of people are going to
like Florida
yeah and like a lot of red States man
it's it's so funny
yeah yeah the pandemic overcrowded yeah
well also the pandemic really like it
was funny one of the things I really I
remember
uh
uh that I thought was weird AOC during
the pandemic went to Florida to party
yeah I mean I'm sure she visited yeah
she went to Florida but it's like
she's so mad at the pilot she's so mad
right at the policies but when it was
over like the timing of it was like when
everyone was starting to unmask and
she's like Florida exists I'm not gonna
not go there
I think that it's funny to have fun in a
place because
it's it's Florida for a reason it's like
you had you know she could have went to
anywhere people go to Florida they go to
Miami where can she go to get a good
beach that isn't a Republican state
California absolutely but it's like far
away maybe she wanted to go somewhere
closer I mean here's here you think like
Democratic senators should only go to
Democratic states absolutely yeah you
don't get to go you don't get to have
fun in a Republican state
unless you voted it for him you know
what I mean it's like yeah so it's like
the floor is lava go to Vermont you
can't even fly over lovely this time of
year yeah
Vermont would be perfect right now the
rocky ass beaches yeah but it's like
cold there so yeah well don't you think
it's a little hypocritical to have a
good time there but enjoy the fruits of
Republican labor against it but maybe
she doesn't enjoy the Republican part
maybe she just enjoys the natural part
the freedom of it yeah that's the
freedom of it that's the Republican part
but Florida is so badly managed like in
terms of environment like they're all
sinking like they built like the
suburban sprawl and swamp land yeah and
they didn't leave enough like swamp to
soak in the water
so it's just like miles of like parking
lot like it was so hard to do and it's
just like it doesn't soak in the water
so yeah I think a lot of a lot a lot of
City
a lot of cities seem to have been poorly
designed yeah you know uh yeah Florida
is definitely one where that just they
also didn't oh Texas also
seems to not be prepared is really flood
prone or is it Dallas ah I don't know
but yeah it's they got their problems
also the the blizzards yeah Texas in
general they weren't the infrastructure
wasn't designed for global warming yeah
right we just decided not to figure that
out we're like huh isn't that funny what
happened didn't it happen hasn't it
happened how many times does it happen I
think at least twice in three years
that's insane because the first time it
happened didn't they say it was a once
in a hundred thousand or yeah they said
it once in a generational blizzard they
said oh this only happens uh whatever
and then it happened again yeah within
the same year or no if not the next year
the year after yeah it was definitely
too close for it to be once in a
generation so it's funny for people the
polar vortex yeah because it's getting
because you think do you think that's
man-made or do you think that that's
just naturally how the planet I think
we're speeding it up for sure we're like
pumping so much [__] like Jon Stewart
was like you don't think that's doing
anything like like the fact that we're
not even trying to look after it we're
like don't don't look at it we're
allowed to do this we have freedoms yeah
yeah yeah we're like What do you think
is
yeah on an industrial scale we're too
powerful to just be like all not giving
a [__] about it yeah
it is I think we are having a a negative
effect we're definitely not helping but
when I looked at the amount of pollution
that China does compared to the United
States yeah
I think it's like not even close but
like overall carbon yeah whatever output
is like uh the West is still largely in
the lead overall from like the 1800s to
now
like all the carbon in the world right
now is mostly from Europe but in terms
of pollution beyond that well yeah just
like overall pollution you think well I
know China is doing a lot
but it's like
if you look at world history they had
the uh you know whatever the Opium Wars
yeah and like how America treated the
Middle East and Africa yeah and North
and South America it's like every
country is like trying to avoid that
and China's like in survival mode it's
like they can't rely on Western Powers
Yeah Yeah to be yeah yeah yeah it I I
I'm not I guess it's not I'm not really
blaming anyone but you know sometimes
you gotta pollute you know what I mean
but it is interesting that
AOC back to her for example somebody
that is so loud
about
saving the earth green New Deal she was
all about that she said that she was mad
at cows I believe farting unless that's
completely made up yeah but I I doubt it
because a lot of people are crazy but
she something about like farming and
meat manufacture and I can understand
that how meat manufacturer is a big part
of pollution that makes sense to me
but also Jets and flying around so it's
like
it's just an unfortunate part of life
the life that we live so if you want to
get on a plane to Miami to party in a
Republican state
but yet you're crying at the border
you know a lot of it is just
performative I'm just insulted at the
performative aspect of it rather than I
like I think if you actually care about
it
then fine
you know but ALC I remember her crying
at the border do you remember that at
the migrants she just was like had a
photo shoot because that's what I love
when I'm sad camera guy that's what I
need you know what I mean yeah and not
to say that people should be getting
treated terrible but you know Biden kept
that going
he didn't do photo shoots yeah that's
the smart he was smart about it oh just
kept the legislation going the
immigration he kept the legend he kept
Trump's Legends he kept all that going
yeah they're still in the cages also
Obama are they yeah opposites yeah I'm
sure they're not getting treated well
absolutely not I I 100 agree I I don't
think they're getting treated well at
all but because a Democrat is in office
no Republicans can't bring it up because
then they'll be like okay let's change
it I'm like no no we don't want to
change it we're just saying yeah they
kind of you did it they're gonna say it
after it's present when when a
republican is in office it's all
[__] yeah they all go back and forth
I think there's about
I think it's about maybe two people that
care in politics yeah that actually
genuinely care and are trying to make
about two maybe three
the rest of his career politicians or
maybe they start like AOC I believe
maybe she came in with a good mind and a
good heart then you just get corrupt
like everybody else and by corrupt I
just mean
you you you you see to the power in
front of you like Nancy Pelosi all that
stuff yeah
she came in with like if things don't
have to change that much this is pretty
we just need to change a few things
exactly yeah and because once she's in
the club now she's getting she's showing
up to parties she went to the Met Gala
yeah I mean yeah AOC went from obscurity
to going to the mecca she handled it so
well though
she killed it I mean no like just the
rise to fame
she's a she's a she's masterful at at uh
social media and she's very charismatic
and she's very smart she's obviously
really smart and charismatic
uh but as far as what she's able to get
done
she's uh
she hasn't really done anything in terms
of uh taking the policy that
she supposedly for and and getting it
enacted she hasn't really done anything
she's not a good politician but I feel
like she's a good like figure to be like
hey this is what the Liberals are like I
mean someone has to do it and I think
she's like pretty good at it just
because she doesn't [__] up too much she
says the right things pretty much most
of the time but like she is like a
mascot but it's like she is a mascot but
that's also a bad thing in a bad because
she's to be too much of a mascot
means that sometimes you're just gonna
say like phrases that the party want you
to say yeah and promote stuff like I
remember she
you know promoted latinx she you know
what I mean remember that latinx like
she was one of the people trying to push
latinx which is like next uh the Fletch
of Ocasio because she's Hispanic yeah
but that's also but no one cares about
that actual Hispanics don't care about
that she's so far removed she's so far
into the uh what do you call it culture
yeah
space of it do you think people should
use latinx
I don't think it matters to actual
latinx people I think yeah if there's a
trans like Sue mochilics
I don't think it matters is the back but
the backpack's still feminine even if
she's whatever
so like you know like yeah I mean if
there's a trans person would do do you
have like because their language is so
based on gender I feel like uh like
people shouldn't be that into their
gender either like changing it or just
being a man or being a woman like people
that are too into their gender I feel
like yeah I was like almost animalistic
but I think it's important to have some
people that are like that
but it's just like I feel like that's
the only thing people have nowadays
because they don't have any economic
freedoms so they're just like yeah I'm a
gender and it's like that's so sad it's
like such a basic thing it's like
bragging about being like a protozoa or
like a simple Olympics yeah identity
yeah becomes their identity yeah like a
lot of girls are like I'm a girl this is
why I do things because yeah I'm a girl
which I think is hot and like a sexy way
it is I'll I'm annoyed at it but I'll
[__] you I'm attracted to it yeah well
yeah I it's
yeah I [__] liberal I [__] my fair
share of liberal white women for sure
yeah but it is super annoying just on a
level of
you know
a lot of people don't actually care
they're just saying the right things
yeah you know
like I I
identify as pretty Progressive you know
but I
hate the Democratic party you know I
mean I'm just thinking about it and it's
funny how people act like it's a it's
it's good what's happening yeah you know
even with affirmative action
things are just more a lot more
complicated right because it was
designed to help black people help
minorities but it actually got to a
point where it was hurting Asian people
did you see that yeah like the uh
getting into Harvard and stuff yeah you
read about that where it was like they
were saying no to qualified Asians yeah
because they were like we got enough for
you guys we need more Browns yeah which
is kind of racism right I mean it's
racism for good but it's racism yeah
it's just funny yeah I think uh
that's
it's like Asians are doing fine yeah I
mean if a few of us have to not go to
Harvard I think it's good I think a lot
of Asians go to Harvard and they become
boring and they become part of the
system yeah and maybe getting kicked out
of Harvard will make you be like oh I
should live my life instead of just
being part of something like a cog in
the wheel I agree also Asians are so
smart they need to be handicapped okay
let's they need to be expelled from
school for a month all right let's give
them up take a break you got you figured
school out
go learn a trade you know what I mean
like figure something out go figure out
how to do a bong rip yeah come on yeah
live life you did it this is this math
is I don't want anybody you don't want a
country of just Asians that haven't
lived life now in charge of everything
yeah yeah so I agree with that but they
got rid of that they got rid of
affirmative action
so now it's just
action
that was just uh negative action yeah
that's just you know [__] uh is Asians
in Harvard it's just all Asian it's just
all yeah it should be you know and white
people
shouldn't even be allowed to go to
school
no I get shot I can't say that yeah
white people need to go to school why
people are struggling right now it's a
tough time for for whites yeah they are
the master race or the superpower but
they are struggling
well also have both every superpower
comes to an end you know
you know every every every uh age
uh uh you know sees every what was it
every civilization at some point
destroys itself yeah right so I think
definitely in America white people are
approaching the
uh and their usefulness
yeah exactly they're like the shuttle
like the booster is falling away
thank you whites yeah we'll take it from
here
we're going to space yeah we don't
[__] we don't need you guys I mean I
love white people because they're like
what we should be to some extent like
not worried about survival just peaceful
happy living Carefree
yeah yeah well you know they're not
going anywhere they're just not gonna be
the majority anymore but they're still
gonna be here
yeah but that's what happens behind when
countries people are [__] you know me
you got a white woman I [__] a white
woman not exclusively but
sometimes that happens yeah
I think white people are
you know it's not like
it's like uh the bleeding out at the
edges like there's some white people
that are like evil and then at the outer
edges it's just like oh they're sort of
evil they're just like blending into the
other races
in terms of yeah well genetically that's
what's happening is the white genius is
receding to the whatever the minority
yeah well we're all are except for like
China or something but there they're
lining up to take pictures of white
people yeah if you can go there you can
[__] impregnate so many people really
yeah interesting that's good to know
yeah I mean it's not easy I gotta get
there man you just need a good website
but then people will try to probably
find you it's like uh over there it's
like Chris Hanson
like what we caught this American trying
to [__] our Chinese women oh really is
such as we confronted funny why why hey
man it's like oh you brought Chopsticks
to this day were you planning on using
these
to eat out her [__]
I'd watch that try that version of the
deadline
you realize this was a five foot two
woman and your penis is eight inches
long
should take a seat
oh man you take your shoes off
look at those big ass feet why don't you
put those big ass feet up take a seat
you want you said you wanted to eat
around Mushu Style
what exactly did you mean by that I
don't know is that what you meant by
Chinese takeout
yes it was called Chinese takeout at the
name of the show I'd watch that yeah
yeah nice try white guy trying to [__]
our beautiful women to file it over with
your yeah that's illegal huh man
communism man
you can't have uh you can't [__] white
people on communism
that makes sense
yeah I had I mean I I [__] everybody I
think I [__] a white woman up
an Asian woman Mexican have you [__] a
black woman yes I lost my virginity to a
black woman really yeah
how was that it was good it shows really
nice
she uh helped me out
sexually was it
uh this was when I was like 22 or 23
right after college oh pretty late okay
yeah I went yeah the whole College
without getting laid wow very
embarrassing congrats good [__] man
that's an accomplishment I kept myself
try people tried right people didn't try
that hard
they were cool with letting this one go
hahaha
I mean I [__] it up there was a girl
that was kind of hitting on me she would
like play footsies with me and then I
like pushed her foot away
I just had no idea what I was doing I
was like a tiger with like a deer for
the like a baby tiger just like yeah
just playing with a deer yeah you just
be instead of eating it you just were
like
befriending it yeah
that's exactly
you don't watch anime no I don't I wish
I did
[__] I thought you were cool man I want
to watch anime I just it's hard to get
into because it's like so crazy it's
like not like anything else it gets
crazy man wait you didn't ever watch
like I watched Avatar I watch Pokemon I
watch Avatar The Last Airbender all
right
I watched Cowboy Bebop yeah the cartoon
or the Netflix no the cartoon right
they're the Japanese did you see the
Netflix one I saw pieces of it it's just
Netflix they be remade they're remaking
uh uh one piece
oh yeah they just don't know when to
stop they did it to death note
who's asking for this
yeah they're like I love Japanese people
I just don't like their art can you get
me like real people to act this out it's
like a cake white people yeah to pretend
that they're Japanese because I don't
even think they're hiring actual
Japanese people oh they're like well we
got this from here in Japanese yeah
they're [__] God they're cultural
appropriate and Anime they're that's why
it sucks yeah because how do you go
wrong with it's got some of the best
stories some of the best movies come
from I believe anime yeah like I think
Matrix
came from was heavily influenced by
anime and the fighting styles and [__] a
lot of [__] uh
was influenced boy yeah yeah yeah
but uh
it's just pure storytelling yeah it's
not actors just being like let me look
sad for
you know 10 seconds right yeah
they're like this guy's sad this guy's
happy oh now he's going to kill his mom
oh they have a pig that's gonna stop him
from doing that
I saw the Miyazaki movies I kind of like
that like yeah that's dope yeah it
captures a feeling like a child lost in
a giant castle it's dope yeah there's a
lot of feeling it's just it's it's great
art you know I mean not to sound like a
[__] communist
[__] why are they sponsored by the
government yeah they are
indirectly I mean like all the best subs
are like Russian mirror Subs yes they've
invested heavily into that for some
reason
um but yeah like that that James Cameron
did it in a private company without the
funding of the government and it was way
harder
yeah that it's that's weird and then
that [__] it's funny because James
Cameron was one of the people who I
think was early early on saying that
Ocean Gate [__] oh yeah he was like I
think he said that he reported him or
something or said yeah he's not safe
yeah it's like we know how to do this
and you're not it's like someone doing
comedy like yeah you know like someone
that just comes on the scene and he's
like I got this comedy thing for you
guys are working way too hard
why don't you just post all your bits on
Instagram
you guys are trying to take time and
craft bits
just post the audience interaction don't
worry it doesn't matter if it's funny
yeah what do you [__] just an idiot
just start headlining deal with that
pressure from day one and see how much
you love comedy then just put your tits
online are your tits out have you tried
putting your titties out
I think it's like the most important
thing is like loving comedy because if
you get big and blow up and then comedy
becomes this horrible thing that you
feel like trapped to and you're not
really good at and you never develop
proper habits because you're never
humble enough to be like Oh I'm bad at
this you'll be like no I'm the man I'm
headlining tonight I can't be like oh I
don't know how to do this it's like you
gotta always have this confidence even
though you don't deserve it
and then like you grow to hate it and it
becomes like a toxic relationship but if
you're like struggling and poor but you
still love doing comedy and you just
keep doing it then like over time you're
gonna have done more comedy than the guy
that burns out really fast volume wise
yeah so for us a hobby method of
training is that you should never work
out till you're sore because then you're
gonna get injured and then you're gonna
not work out because that's the biggest
killer of talent promising Talent is
injuries yeah yeah facts yeah it's the
the long run people who can't see
I think the end game
and the longevity yeah you know that's
if you just
and it's like a relationship you gotta
treat it positively comedy's my [__] I
mean yeah I'm married to the game yeah
it is like and you can't approach it
from anger or hatred or no yeah
wanting to [__] on the Jews all the time
laughs
because eventually it's hard yeah it's
hard yeah because I mean they deserve it
but you gotta there's other things
they're so easy to hate history doesn't
lie for some reason Jews are just
designed to be hateable
I mean Kanye made some good points
that's all that's right I'm kidding I
think uh Jews were great
um
yeah you gotta say I mean yeah that's
Jewish people are amazing this is all
comedy this is yeah this is not intended
to I just have observed the fact that
Jewish people have been uh you know at
the
to you know the bad end of uh sourdeal
who the Jews just they're like ethnic
minority like the Holocaust or like yeah
you know what okay let me say this and
this might not be politically correct
the hot first of all I'll admit the
Holocaust was bad okay but
people don't talk about the benefits of
the Holocaust Holocaust like the movies
like Schindler's List come on man like
you would have not got a Shameless list
there'd be no Woody Allen yeah yeah I
mean without the Holocaust there's so
many good Jewish there's more than six
million Jews right now they're not
coming up with Schindler's List
right
and those are the ones that we may not
need I survive the ones that died were
probably worse the ones that died
I'm just saying there's a balance yeah
no there's no I that's a joke but you
know because they're trying to talk
about the benefits of slavery oh yeah
about that your skills that you learn
exactly yeah so it's benefits of slavery
it's insane yeah Republicans rap yeah
it's
and slavery yeah there'd be no you would
understand Tupac you'd be rapping a
Swahili
that what's funny
for them to even include that you know
it's like let's let's also you know what
they're doing they're trying to justify
slavery and also justify unpaid
internships at the same time yeah
they're not too greedy look
you guys that's what you're saying you
know he learned how to sing that's not
terrible yeah it's like a lot of good
things where's Motown it's not in Africa
it's in Detroit
how are you gonna get to Detroit yeah
from Tanzania you've got a free boat
right bam a free boat ride
singing It's like it came from the heart
that they can [__] yeah no the talent
that came from slavery yeah is almost
worth it yeah that NFL
all that stuff we deliver it
something about having ancestors that
went through horrible trauma makes you
six foot seven
yeah it makes you more talented yeah
something like even with Jews something
about getting burned in the oven
it really creates pressure really does
create time in that sense like yeah
that's
you gotta you have to have some sort of
Oppression
there's not so many white people suck so
many white women suck yeah you see
Barbie no no yeah I heard it's crushing
a PR uh Oppenheimer
it is it's also crushing
a pre capitalism and the patriarch is it
is it like a work movie oh my God a
hundred percent so do they ever say it
like I saw Transformers and they were
like I'm against buying cable because
I'm against the needless emporic nature
of capitalism it's like oh [__] they're
subsuming the criticisms of capitalism
that would have been
that would have been an acceptable level
of political speak getting into media
like what Barbie was that that was not
because what you just said was a side
character so it was it it's not that
subtle but it's an it's a like a one-off
yeah this Barbie from beginning to end
hits you over the head if you somebody
tweeted this I don't know who said it
but they say if you take a shot every
time the word patriarchy if they say a
patriarchy not only do they say it if
you take a shot every time they say it
you're dead
the first I kind of like that though
there then you you'll love that you'll
love Barbara because every the whole
movie is the patriarchy is bad uh Ken
minute or dumb men are dumb yeah
Barbie's World yeah but not just in
Barbie's World men are dumb in the real
world
it's like everything everywhere all at
once but pretty much there's a lot of
multi multi-dimensional movies happening
yeah you know like I blame Marvel they
really opened up the floodgates to
multi-dimensional stuff yeah I kind of
hate it yeah it's like just tell a story
like yeah you don't have to like blow my
mind with science that isn't even real
like I'm not learning you're like making
me feel like I learned yeah no the
Barbie movie I mean without ruining it
it's so over the head
man with the message of the patriarchy
is bad and the men are evil yeah
and they're not even shy about it and
Ken is actually the low-key best part of
the movie Ryan Gosling yeah Ryan Gosling
yeah he killed it well yeah I think
that's horrible men are amazing actors I
think it's just annoying to like have a
woman be like
you know like really arrogant and
entitled no matter what the gender is
it is but it's it's very specifically
white women I haven't met too many
non-white women well black women are
more into like uh you know social
justice and actual change like they're
tied they're invested in it yeah but
white women have no skin in the game
they're just all Theory it's it's
cosplay white woman cosplay because it
doesn't directly affect them
so they get into feminism and they take
the fact that
you know uh men do dominate yeah the uh
the world and positions of power and
they take that
and they go we'll see women are
oppressed but it's like but you're still
a white woman they white women like
that's why Bill Burr is great because he
goes after
that white liberal woman thing of you're
bad too yeah you know because you're not
perfect
whatever problems you have like feminism
there's so many white women that are so
in your face about feminism
and
and then I know so many black women that
yeah they're
feminists but they're just not in your
face about it because like you said
they're met with so much oppression
every day yeah at the end of the day
they have to survive you have to survive
women walking around they're just like
appalled at it with their privileged
yeah just like oh they're trusting their
feelings but their feelings haven't
evolved and grown into in a pressure
cooker it grew yeah involved in like a
weird environment yeah it's crazy and so
so Barbie is a perfect example uh of
white women and like also Barbie as a as
a toy
if you're woke and they kind of touch on
this in the film it's very problematic
the measurement of Barbie is unrealistic
it's not even close to how humans are
yeah it's like prizing this one very
specific body type when we know that
there's other body types out there but
do when do you when you see a woman that
looks like that
is it like hot anymore because I feel
like with the ass thing
the ass thing has really changed the
thing on models like back in the day
models used to be the hottest thing ever
but now if you don't have an ass it's
like a lot of men don't want to [__]
with you yeah fat asses are in yeah
before it used to be skinny little
[__] whatever white women yeah like
King Kong that white woman yeah it's
like just flat asses yeah nothing but
now
which is great maybe the Kardashians
played a lot the Kardashians I think
played a role in that in making changing
rights I mean I hope not but I think
you're right I think they did I think
they changed a lot but what what what
generally speaking because they're from
that culture they're used to like actual
people yeah and then they're like hey
let's show us what show them what we
actually like and yeah and now they're
not even real people by the way like
their bodies are fake yeah but but the
design though the fat ass and Barbies
Armenian Barbies yeah they're like and
they're thick and and before the
Kardashians it was
a kind of normal Natalie Portman
that's kind of yeah like uh Elizabeth
Banks yeah exactly this [__] normal
Rachel McAdams yeah it just couldn't be
more mediocre not ugly but I think they
have beautiful faces I think that's what
they're very cute faces but the bottoms
are nothing and then Kardashians came
with the fat ass now yeah Scarlett
Johansson with the fat ass also scar
Joe's out here rocking you know yeah
she's a white girl she was just waiting
for the black queens to raise her up he
was yeah she her time is now she was
always because she was always a black
widow which is kind of racist
isn't she
that ass is yeah that's why that's
that's why from the waist down yeah yeah
she's half black can't always style yeah
that's hilarious her I guess other women
too Iggy oh yeah
yeah she fell off that's uh she did she
did fall off but she I liked her yeah
but it's like yeah you can't adopt that
no it's but take that skinny European
[__] out of here man yeah you know it's
good and I'm gonna put the Kardashians
they suck though but that's all the only
people that like that are Euro trash
like like people that go to like house
clubs yeah
but like if you're an American you you
want an ass
yeah
it's the cellulite is
definitely uh you know who else loves
asses as Mexican men
yeah and black men obviously but Mexican
men they love a good ass yeah what you
just need to be thick I think all around
you know I mean not just an ass but like
yeah like if you're not fed like soft if
you're not if you don't have the shape
of people like squeezable like yeah like
feel her like be plump yeah they want to
lay on something soft that's not also
the end titties make a nice pillow yeah
I mean it's like it's the best dude I
was walking at an airport and there's
this black woman with like tight pants
and like an amazing booty and this
Mexican guy was just filming it
yeah you got to man sometimes you ever
been there where you just your answer
like damn like I was kind of side eyeing
him like come on man
like just look it up online like what
are you doing here all right I want to
remember this particular ass
sometimes like as long as she's cool
with it did he ask for permission no of
course not he didn't even oh talk to her
well he's canceled then
but yeah I mean I think uh I think I
think like
some people like to show off their
bodies like I saw a dude with like a
tank top walking his dog yeah it's like
you didn't have to wear a tank top like
how much heat are you actually expelling
yeah well also just go shirtless yeah I
mean it's like the tank top is such a
annoying thing because I was like yeah
just don't wear a shirt I'm too skinny
for a tank top I just look like uh like
a five-year-old
like just standing out there
you need big arm you need to look like
have like a manly yeah if you're not
built for because a tank it does look
ridiculous if you don't have good arms
just out there looking like your your
parents are late
yeah waiting
yeah it's
it doesn't make me feel confident in
myself
like yeah hey it's like emphasizing my
arms and it's just like not it's like
you know it's not
worth emphasizing yeah also like you
know wife beaters just the name too it's
like
you know you you look your arms like I'm
I'm not beating my wife you know I mean
not like or I might like if I have a
weapon yeah you know what I mean but
then you see those boxers that are just
arms oh yeah I like Hypno champ from
Pokemon
they're just like all right and like
you're trying to hit them but it's like
trying to hit someone that's like got
like a tennis racket in front of you
yeah
yeah that's I thought you just said you
didn't play oh no you did watch I didn't
watch Dragon Ball Z and Pokemon I
watched Pokemon okay the essentials okay
yeah I was about to say the essentials
package yeah yeah yeah I mean I think
girls watch that [__] too I mean a lot
of you ever go to like the Anime
conventions or anything like that I went
to I went to one I went to the one in LA
man some of the most beautiful women
yeah I have ever seen
are [__] nerds like they're just like
you know I mean dressed up as some yeah
Inuyasha or some you know character
where it's like what the [__] but
they're
uh yeah it's like a lot of like hot
women you think it's because they see
the real world and it's not as beautiful
as they are but in an anime World
everyone can be beautiful and they just
are so I feel at home or do you think
it's like no I think they're these women
are attract or like their minds are
beautiful because they they're beautiful
on the outside and they're like they
like happiness and emotions and like
their brains are like
uh you know they want beautiful ideas as
well and then anime yeah ideas I think
sometimes I think sometimes hot women
maybe they were like ugly maybe they
don't know escape the real world they
were actually a lot of them definitely
were hideous growing up yeah and then
grew into their beauty I hope so
be weird if you were hot at like four
yeah I mean but there's some four
there's some hot four Heroes don't act
like oh they're saying you're full of
children we're gonna sit here and act
like we haven't all seen when you see a
beautiful kid are you like that's a
beautiful kid are you like that person
is gonna be hot in the future because I
think there's a difference I don't know
I mean in the in the future obviously
it's weird to go that that
eight-year-old is hot now yeah that's
weird but what's normal is to go that
eight-year-old it's like gonna be
[__]
smoking yeah a few years yeah
but some people don't like uh Arya Stark
from Game of Thrones yes she was a
beautiful kid and then she like
I don't know what happened
oh really she's not a hot adult now
she's not no she looks like a little kid
that like she looks like Gary Coleman oh
that's it that's a shame yeah that but
that's a perfect example of somebody who
not at the time was not hot I'm not
saying she was hot yeah at the time but
you could just go hmm
if this person's gonna be there was a um
the the little girl from The Bernie Mac
Show
I don't know if you saw them at Bernie
Mac's show but this is there was a
little girl on there it's a dope show
you guys it's a classic there's a little
girl on there like if you if you see her
now yeah she's [__] one of the most
gorgeous women I've ever seen and you
know her as a little kid is the little
girl but isn't that like life like if
you live in a village you're like oh
there's that little kid being so cute
and then she grows up being like damn I
didn't realize that
I could uh you know pursue you now can I
it is yeah it is I mean once people hit
that that legal image although to be
fair I thought she was cute even when
she was a kid yeah but I was also a kid
let me just be clear I wasn't okay I was
a kid that wanted to [__] another kid
what the [__] another kid I saw her go
she's cute yeah as a fellow kid yeah
you're like as a kid that's judged on my
cuteness this is a kid that's you know
you know and doing well in this game
that I'm playing yeah absolutely I think
we're around the same age which is why
I'd [__] the [__] out of her right now
she is gorgeous man yeah but yeah that
is uh and sometimes it'd be like that
man kids grow up to be sexy as [__]
I mean where do you think sexy people
come from they had to be kids at some
point yeah you're right you're supposed
to not notice when someone's on the path
to being one of the greatest things a
human can be
foreign
if I see a eight-year-old
she's just making baskets from the
three-point line and just not missing a
shot I can't acknowledge that's a future
Jordan
yeah but if you see someone with a
perfect nose
got the cheekbones for days
I can't go yo that's the future no yeah
but you can't describe the body you
can't be like banging pot
yeah but yeah I mean yeah it really
depends like some kids have it all
figured out and then they go some awry
but most of the time like you know like
the kids in my school that in my school
that were hot they all grew up to be
pretty hot adults too the kids that were
like Attractive people in my school oh
you can tell you could you can pretty
much tell well then there are the ones
that are ugly kids that girl [__]
yeah like that's
yeah some people are cocoons yes yeah
they're just morphing in there usually
like fat people like men are fat men
yeah especially they turn out to be like
strong yeah big people or yeah even
chubby are kind of girls chubby girls
yeah they turn out to be like [__]
just smoking hot and that's how they
develop a personality I've never met a
hot chick a hot woman who's very
attractive that uh has a personality
that was not ugly yeah or if they
weren't ugly
their parents died in a plane accident
you know what I mean it's like some
tragedy happened like you know I mean
life [__] you over some way yeah and
that's what the basketball personality
is yeah that's really what comes through
you know and people who are boring
obviously haven't been through
very dramatic events how could you if
you're born as [__] yeah you know like
that's there's nothing to compliment
yeah what you already have yeah there's
nothing there yeah for sure
but yeah I think that's
you I I mean good luck man being with a
a normal person a normal Woman white
woman because
I think that
it's definitely does she understand your
schedule because sometimes that's hard
for that's I was just about to say that
sometimes it's hard for regular people
to understand
that which is out we're just yes these
hours are like insane yeah you know you
you're gone but
she wants me to come home
late at night yeah as opposed to like
what doing shows and stuff hanging out
at bars
yeah it's tough it's tough man because
that and and that makes sense but
like you said it is a relationship yeah
so I loved it I've invested a lot of
time into it and I think we're in a good
place and it's something that I've
always wanted to do as someone who's
been is this your first single uh
relationship no it's not but
they've only been like six months
relationships this is your first like
serious one uh this is six months now so
we'll see but yeah yeah I have a
beautiful like relationship with her and
I've spent a lot of time and energy into
it just like taking a break from Comedy
whether on purpose or not I don't know
but yeah I want to get back into it and
I don't know how it's gonna work out but
yeah it's like I can't you know do both
and I do need to do comedy but yeah
we're just gonna figure it out but yeah
it's it's hard to do the time thing
well yeah at least you live in the same
state right the city I know people who
do [__] that long distance that's
ridiculous yeah I'm I can't even imagine
that right now
but I know it works because like you're
just thinking about them oh yeah but how
do you see each other enough like what
is that like why can't you just be like
okay this is great but like it's I'm
you're not here let me find someone
closer like at some point we're all like
McDonald's
like why would I drive over there yeah
24 hours
I just can't get them but yeah yeah with
a local person it's like well yeah it's
convenient you're here we're all making
it work it's so yeah it's there's
definitely somebody there's other people
I do believe that
there's multiple people some people
think
in terms of soul mates yeah there's some
people think there's just one soul mate
and then I I don't know if I agree with
that I think that there's there's people
many people you can make it work with
people that you can have a very strong
relationship with to think about just
one yeah
you might have found is it your person
and then that's great yeah but
you know if if one of you were to die
but there is like a nice thing about a
friend that you've known from birth who
knows everything you don't have to
explain anything and they've known
somebody that has enough information on
you yeah like that's like a long-term
relationship that is nice at certain
point they do collect too much
information
all right well now I gotta marry this
[__] yeah you need a fresh start at
some point to just be like uh yeah let
me
let me just get someone who doesn't
think I'm a horrible person yeah
yeah if you learn with somebody for too
long you either gotta marry him or kill
them yeah you can't have somebody
knowing you're stories just out there in
the world yeah that's not vulnerable to
you yeah
I think like tough too yeah it's like
if you're with someone for a long time
they're gonna remember all the negatives
they're not gonna remember all the
positives yeah because the negatives hit
you harder and it's more like affects
you it stands out more stands out more
so just yeah naturally you're just gonna
grow to accrue enough to hate someone
enough like bad things have happened
yeah yeah that's why I think it's best
to
to end it before you start hating
people each other you know what I mean
yeah like that's I think that like I'm
on good
terms with like all of my exes there's
nobody where I'm like
it's not toxic yeah you know like do you
are you do you talked in your exes or
you're at least no they're all toxic
they all talk I
broke up with them dramatically almost
every single one oh really yeah I think
so I mean you know sometimes
you know people are toxic that's the
thing like like I mean about it
sometimes it ends just mutually like it
just doesn't work out yeah but then if
somebody hurt this the other person or
if somebody was just a [__] crazy
person
then yeah you I am a fan of removing
people from your life
yeah I cut them off yeah I mean it
wasn't always my choice but
I don't know it's like um I don't really
um get too attached so maybe that's why
really okay yeah I mean
um I wish
that you know I would talk to some of
them but you know
I don't think that a lot of them want to
talk to but yeah I don't really that's
not really
uh uh my I don't really set up but I
don't really think about that as an
important thing for me I'm just more
focused on like making the relationship
now good but yeah I mean I if I were a
better person I'd probably be on better
terms with a lot of my ex's well no also
sometimes like I said sometimes if it
if if it ended badly I understand
not being on Good Times Like That X if
somebody cheated on somebody or or you
know like somebody did something it was
like that's not cool
yeah [__] that person sometimes people
are bad people
you know and you have to separate
yourself
but
I definitely uh if I've ever felt gotten
that point to uh with somebody where I'm
like this isn't going this might not go
well then I tend to just like
immediately pull away yeah that's what
all my bad relationships have been is
like me not pulling away right away
right yeah because there's a red flag
right like crazy people give you red
flags yeah they that at a certain point
and this is true for men or women at a
certain point you'll be with someone and
they'll give you several signs where
this isn't right
but you choose to stay with them yeah
and then that's when [__] gets crazy
yeah right and then yeah because they
think they can do that now yeah and they
keep doing it
yeah yeah man yeah that's [__] I got
several friends that are just [__]
you know
with people I'm like why do you keep
making the same mistake but it's hard
yeah once you get addicted to someone
yeah
yeah so it's like and it's hard to get
other people to [__] you all the time it
is consistently yeah I mean I I don't
know I guess it's not that maybe not for
you but
for most men
for the average looking man maybe not I
mean I don't know I mean it can't be
there for you I mean you're [__] out
here you must be crushing it you know
what I mean before I mean before I was
like literally yeah yeah I was doing all
right yeah you know women this holes out
here yeah it's like yeah even when I was
doing all right it's like most people
weren't [__] me it's like one out of
every thousand person you mean which is
great
if that's all it took just meet thousand
person one of them's gonna [__] you yeah
yeah but yeah I mean it sounds like your
numbers I don't know I feel like a lot
of women like don't like me really yeah
like maybe because of the whole kissing
thing I'd like kiss a lot of people and
kill Tony
people kiss people all the time just
because yours are filmed yeah does it
mean it's like who hasn't kissed a bunch
of people yeah you know what I mean like
people but also like sort of like my you
know I didn't approach you know
sexuality from the conventional route
and I think a lot of people are tied to
that and they resent the fact that I got
to skip past all the roadblocks that
they had set up
but I'm also like a huge in cell so oh
really oh okay what do you think about
Jordan Peterson I hate him really yeah
what I don't know man I mean
he makes some good points that's all I'm
saying I'm just saying do women deserve
to vote
it's Up For Debate you can agree I don't
disagree with them it presents the
question he presents the question which
is important yeah debate is important
yeah you know what we need open dialogue
about everything everything's a coin
flip everything's on the table Yeah the
second you take it on the table whether
it's voting rights for women
or you know I mean just general rights
yeah like should we hunt people for
sport yeah
it's on the table maybe maybe not just
because you think one way doesn't mean
that there aren't 50 of people that
think the other way and that's the thing
I hate about today especially uh in this
social media culture no one ever
is willing to admit when they were wrong
yeah you know because I am against
hunting people for sport but maybe I
just haven't seen the right data you
know so maybe I haven't heard the right
argument yeah I have an open mind
yeah I was against uh uh pineapples on
pizza
and then I and then yeah I tried it if
you change your mind once then how can
you rely on yourself ever again
absolutely yeah you can't yeah that's
the tricky thing man you got to be open
everything uh that way you can't focus
on something in particular yeah exactly
who you think is the most Intel person
is Jordan Peterson no but he's he's a
fan like in most Intel people are huge
fans of Jordan what about Andrew Taylor
I should have said Andrew Tate I hate
Andrew Tate as well okay because Andrew
Tate I think even more than Peterson is
like King and so he's like Andrew Andrew
Tate is like Jordan Peterson for like
Urban people yeah well he's like
he's so extreme because Jordan
at least tries to have a normal
voice about it he speaks in a regular
human way about things Tate
is such a character he's like a a Alex
Jones level I mean if Alex Jones what
but first you're a ridiculous person he
is a ridiculous person smoking cigars
talking about the Matrix all the time
you drink water you're not a man you
gotta drink Sparkling Water
that is it's just like weird rules it's
like girls when they're like oh if a guy
eats cha you know if he picks up a
broccoli with a fork and then doesn't
you know put it down or whatever yeah
yeah and they're like I'm not gonna date
him no I mean but so you might like the
Barbie movie or you might it depends I
think women are great yeah you want to
just end it oh we don't oh yeah are you
oh yeah we can always do it again okay
yeah I just have a neck injury
okay yeah oh you have a neck injury
really yeah oh I didn't know that oh no
it's okay it's uh yeah